bella tanti ragazzi e benvenute questo
in questo nuovo video sono page e
passiamo nel mio meraviglioso nuovo
studio non sto scherzando questa
location temporaneamente non ci saranno
anche in europa casa mia comunque non
potevo non inaugurare questa location
incredibile con un video altrettanto
incredibile perché oggi i ragazzi e il
25esimo anniversario
c'è poi c'è stato deciso insieme di
versare o di crash bandicoot cos'è crash
bandicoot ma non me lo so spiegare però
ce l'ho tatuato e sulla su 4 da sul
polpaccio di tutto questo non è che
spendi con questa è acqua q ma che cosa
parla fare con chi non molla come tutti
voi sapete lista uno soltanto lato sono
falli che ci medico ma soprattutto ho
già giocato anche smentito il 4 sulla
playstation phone ma è finalmente uscito
con il 25esimo anniversario per
playstation 5 qui adesso si può giocare
sulla invece un 5 con tutte le migliorie
grafiche che c'è e proprio per
inaugurare questa questo gameplay
fantastico volevo sfidare breezer alla
fine una sfida è partita dalla minore
sfiderò appunto sul crash bandicoot 4
come voglio strutturare questa sfida
caro breezer voglio sfidarti a delle
prove a tempo usa la prova a tempo di
crescenti ma semplicemente quando
finisci un livello di crash bandicoot
puoi di giocarlo cercando di battere il
record di tempo per appunto fare tegole
speed rami che vedete su you tube rover
ma questa volta proverò a farlo sfilando
appunto il melbourne streeter che
sicuramente sarà in grado di tenervi
testa non di battere perché impossibile
però allora se noi partiamo all'inizio
io posso allora provate un po comincia
dal momento in cui tu prendi il
cronometro che sono spiego io che gioca
da crescenti che da quando sono nato
così praticamente to previsto cronometro
eco il compagno ma lo faccio vedere
mentre cipro esame lo proviamo subito
vedere se esco a fare un tempo buono per
uno scopo questo è il primo
allora praticamente così cosa consiste
questa sfida bisogna fare deve aprire il
livello e del minor tempo possibile
ma la cosa divertente che in giro per la
mappa ci sono delle caste che se colpite
vanno a stoppare il tempo quindi una
cosa veramente utile siccome mi state
vedendo che sto continuando a
schiacciare il tasto quadrato per fare
questa cosa della giravolta classica
ripe splendido perché lui sto facendo
non è perché sono pazzo ma perché è
questa cosa striscia non lo sapeva
meglio noti come facciamo interno
se tu vai a ritmo di giravolta il
personaggio ovvero crash bandicoot andrà
ad una velocità maggiore pronti di farla
piccoli sono danno ma sapete io trovo
che quando spies faccio schifo io e
basta
c'è da di allora specie una lancia a mio
favore
c'è da dire che è difficile devi fare
tutto nel livello è facilissimo però è
difficile farlo
al tempo stesso è stato beneficerà che
tu devi anche sfruttare il danno che ti
fai ion perché con
con la sua fuga è tutto qualche
d'accordo sulla gamba una hit da parte
degli avversari bonus e immortale che ha
colpito non ho preso il treno sopra la
de ma niente coprendo bene bene bene
bene stanno tastando meglio occhio
breezer che può essere arrivato in 20
secondi m.ma 21 non è male poi non so se
mai più veloce tv vorrei lo faccio lo
stesso nel dubbio
ok mamma mia che porta in faccia
compreso l'aveva niente io mi ricordo
ragazzi che sta roba la facevo già su
mastros le une quando giocato ad astros
playmouth permetterci un 5 giocato anche
con le mappe che fai ha tempo per ciò
che arrivate nel tempo sono stato tra i
primi non ricordo quanti cento forza al
mondo quando la fede non era più
riuscita era serviva questa volta è
difficile raga perché non vengono
assolutamente casse per sbloccare per
fermare il tempo e video occhio 115 non
so se vuoi ma sta roba
non ho idea io ho fatto pure 15 ma va
bene allora teniamo 115 quindi free
rider occhio e 1 15 59 ma prima di
provare a farlo ma fare 53 secondi li
voglio provare a fare anche il livello 2
per la sfida sarà su due livelli prova
anche a fare questo ritorno sul primo
per vedere se dico a migliorarmi sono
già questi due non sono male è sbriciola
non sono male ma posso fare di meglio
partiamo subito perché non se ne scopare
allora io comunque stato
non vale ero più veloce la prima volta
la come ero più veloce la prima volta
che ci ho provato aiuto ok buono buono
non ci è arrivato qualche volta ma come
fai
l'ultima mania sta cadendo da
conservatori concentrato una sede
bellissimo attiva dovevo prendere la gm
finto un babbo era facilissimo va a
prenderla di nt rega bellissimo come ho
fatto questo bellissimo no mamma mia con
salvatori ha convinto che salvarono
stoffa bene
ora manca solo mancato lo mancato frisa
cioè ma almeno due secondi di vantaggio
mannaggia non manca polimor cavate
ragazzi voluto offendere i visi sono
veramente un pirla sono veramente un
piena era veramente facile ma annunciato
meno mancato lo store è che i greci mac
oppure qua mamma mia
dai raga mamma mi è difficile o farla
tempo ragazzi un casino ma veramente mi
sono mai impegnato così nella mia vita
ma mai ma mai poteva anche andarci con
tranquillamente perfetto normale o la
maschera posso sfonda qualsiasi cosa
possono sfornare tutto fratelli perfetto
ladies con a tutto con la maschera
sforna altri toscana tutto perfetto 15
59 un minuto dopo minuto
l'ho fatto i lunghi nudo preciso quanto
quanto fa per la reliquie incredibile 43
secondi pro migliore è il primo raga ma
non è che devi avere perché ci sono dei
piccoli poteri che sblocchi un mese
vorrei riavere quei criteri avanzati per
andare ai colpi del over perché lo sto
facendo standard
non voglio far spoiler diciamo che è un
potere molto figo trovo l'altro fa
troppo vero come fa andare così veloce
non si non è possibile cioè praticamente
c'è una roba che continui a roteare di
continuano e una spiegazione che
l'italia non ha un senso ma non fa
niente bene non sto andando male per i
miei cani probabilmente per un hosting
rateali staranno sanguinando gli occhi e
per ogni titolo parte del mio meglio
va bene 37 prendo quando devo fare 50 30
ormai parlare non fa niente ciro
bellissimo conoscano benissimo mi sa
cosa devo fare
poi stato fare cambi cosa devo fare
queste come faccia poi 53 secondi è un
miracolo di esserci guarda un minuto e 2
attenzione no corpo demonio orco
ho perso un secondo comunque sono
trovata il primo cambio street
adesso tocca a te tocca a te cercare di
battere perché se riusciamo a un
punteggio migliore del mio dubito perché
qua jaime king
spero che tu riesca ad essere
all'altezza però bilancio che cospira
grande voglio creare un crash bandicoot
25 anni come chi come il sottoscritto ma
io che rispetti che cresciamo uguali in
un universo parallelo fra spendi
conosciamo da quando farintesa un
polpaccio non lo sappiamo ma spero che
vi sia piaciuto e mi piace anche
quel tizio che ci si chiede come sempre
non ho telecomando però siamo in
situazione un po strane ci vediamo a lo
possiamo il bel ragazzo
[Musica]